All right, today we are diving
back into the haunted manner of
our Jinvest Halt for a second
attempt that goes, well,
disastrously.
We've got a party of adventures.
They are rested, they're
regrouped, and they are about to
learn a really brutal lesson in
a place that's literally
designed to kill you.
Sometimes being cautious is the
most dangerous thing you can do.
Let's breakdown how one tiny
moment of hesitation snowballed
into a full on desperate
retreat.
And this right here, this is the
entire point of the story.
You see, in a place as dangerous
as Arjun Volstholt, the normal
rules of survival just get
thrown out the window.
We're about to see how 1
character trying to be careful,
trying to find the safest
footing, actually becomes the
trigger for a horrifying ambush.
It's the perfect example of how
hesitation can get you killed.
So the party's new plan is all
about one thing, speed.
Their first try was slow, it was
methodical, and it got them
absolutely routed.
So this time they're going back
in through this ruined ballroom,
and the idea is just shock and
awe, going fast, overwhelm,
whatever got them before.
But as we're about to see, a
plan that relies completely on
speed just falls to pieces the
second someone slows down.
And here, you can see exactly
where it all goes wrong.
The plan starts off perfectly.
Three of the party members,
Urihorn, Tracidor and Derman,
they execute.
They get through to the next
room no problem.
But then there's Radley, the
Eldritch Knight.
He just pauses for a split
second.
He's looking for stable ground
in all the rubble.
And that one moment of caution,
That's the fatal mistake that
springs the trap.
And the result is just
overwhelming.
We're not talking one or two
spiders.
Nine of them.
And these things are massive,
OK?
Each one is the size of a horse.
They just drop from the ceiling
on these thick, disgusting webs.
And instantly, Radley is cut off
from his friends.
The safe path he was looking for
is now a kill zone.
And he is completely, totally
alone.
The rest of the party doesn't
even realize their night isn't
with them until they hear it.
BOOM.
The sound of his Thunder wave
spell.
Just this loud, desperate blast
of magic.
They turn back, and what they
see is a total nightmare.
Radley's fighting for his life,
but he is hopelessly
outnumbered.
He gets bitten, poisoned, makes
a desperate run for the door,
only to get caught in a spray of
thick, sticky webbing.
And that's when the poison just
completely overwhelms him.
The source material uses this
absolutely chilling line to
describe it.
He collapses like an abandoned
marionette from the doorway.
His friends don't just see him
fall, they see the fight just
drain out of him.
All his strength is just gone.
It looks completely hopeless.
What happens next is just pure
desperate chaos.
Derrimon and Eurohorn charge
back in, They start hacking
Radley free while Traxidor gets
a stabilizing spell ready.
But even as they're dragging him
to safety, another one of those
huge spiders lunges out for the
final kill, and it only gets cut
down at the very last second.
Traxidor's final healing spell
is a total Hail Mary on a guy
who has already stopped
breathing, but somehow it's the
gamble that saves his life.
So after that incredibly close
call, the party has to switch
things up.
The ground floor is clearly a
death trap, so they head
upstairs.
This time, they use a spell of
silence to try and get the
element of surprise back on
their side.
You know, they're trying to
outsmart the Manor, but as
they're about to find out, Argon
was told has plenty of ways to
trap its prey.
So they're moving down a hallway
and then slam.
A wall of solid magical stone
just materializes out of thin
air behind them.
There was no trigger, no trap.
They missed the house itself,
just decided they weren't
allowed to leave.
And then the real trap shows
itself as these spectral
soldiers start gliding right
through the solid walls around
them.
Now, this is a huge tactical
problem.
As you can see here, their
physical weapons are totally
useless.
Swords, arrows, they just pass
right through these phantom
warriors like they're not even
there.
But the ghost swords, Oh, those
are very, very real.
This immediately puts their
heaviest hitters on the
sidelines and forces them to
completely change their
strategy.
Brute force is useless.
Only magic can hurt these
things.
And this is where the cleric
tracks the door.
Basically becomes the MVP.
He unleashes his divine power,
this wave of pure faith called
Turn Undead.
For these spectral soldiers,
it's like a holy flash bang.
Most of them just recoil and
terror.
They can't stand the energy.
It doesn't destroy them, but it
buys the party the few crucial
seconds they need to focus all
their magic on the 1 ghost that
managed to resist it.
With the ghosts dealt with, they
turn their attention to a barred
door and Radley, the same guy
who is literally moments from
death, just puts all of his
remaining strength into it and
splinters the wood open.
You know, after fighting enemies
they couldn't even touch.
Finally facing a problem that
can be solved with pure muscle
must have felt incredibly good.
And behind that door, they find
something that might just be a
game changer.
It's a small dusty coffer, and
inside are 4 potions of
invulnerability.
I mean, this is a massive find.
Each one of these can make
someone temporarily immune to
all harm.
It's not just a lucky break,
it's a powerful tool that might
actually give them a real
fighting chance in this
impossible place.
So, feeling like they've pushed
their luck about as far as it
can go, the party decides to
retreat outside to regroup.
They get out of the Manor and
they see that mysterious wagon
they heard earlier is gone.
It didn't leave empty handed
though.
It it left a package.
Right there in the middle of
their camp is a single freshly
made coffin, and you can tell
it's new.
The wood isn't rotten, the nails
are clean.
The message here could not be
clear.
The danger isn't just inside
those walls.
Death is out here, and it's
waiting for them.
But it's not just a general
threat.
It is deeply personal.
Because expertly carved right
into the lid is a name.
Radley Fulthorn, the very same
man who just barely escaped
being eaten by giant spiders.
This changes everything.
It means someone is watching
them, someone knows who they
are.
And someone has already prepared
his grave.
So this raises A terrifying
question, right?
What does this even mean?
Is it a warning from the Lord of
this land, Strod?
Is it some kind of psychological
taunt from the revenants inside
the Manor?
Or is there some other unseen
player messing with them?
They pry the coffin open and
it's empty, which somehow only
makes it even more dreadful.
This isn't just a threat, it's
an invitation.
At this point they're exhausted
and completely unnerved by the
coffin.
The party decides they just
can't go on.
They may camp outside hoping to
just rest, but in the shadow of
Arghin Vest Holt, there's no
such thing as a real rest.
They set up a two person watch,
just trying to survive until
morning, but of course there's
no rest to be found.
As you can see on the timeline
in that gloomy pre dawn light,
Derman spots glowing eyes coming
towards them.
It's animated scarecrows,
enemies they've fought before.
The attack is sudden, it's
brutal, and while they managed
to fight them off, the victory
cost them everything.
It drains the very last of their
reserves, and this chart just
visualizes how dire things have
become.
I mean, just look at their
resources.
They're down to their last few
spells, so their main weapon
against all these horrors is
basically gone.
Their stamina is shot after
fighting 3 battles back-to-back,
and maybe most importantly,
their morale is completely
shattered.
They've survived, sure, but they
have absolutely nothing left in
the tank for another fight.
So as the first pale light of
dawn starts to break, they make
the only decision they can.
They break camp.
They turn their backs on the
haunted manner of Argenvostholt.
They run.
And that leaves us with the
final, really chilling question.
OK, they escaped the Manor, but
that coffin proves the threat
isn't just tied to 1 building.
Their next stop is a winery, a
place they're hoping will be
safe.
But in a cursed land ruled by a
creature like Strad, you have to
wonder, is escaping one
nightmare just the fastest way
to run straight into the next
one?